meet inform a dynamic shape display
created by researchers at MIT Media Lab
in Boston this clip is amazing it shows
you how advanced our technology has
gotten not only on a phone call can you
now see the other person you can
actually move your hand at one end and
on the other side of the earth you can
manipulate an object I'd love one of
these when I'm calling home because not
only can I talk to people I can annoy
them by poking them so how can Saad
reach out and poke someone this is
called a dynamic shape display and an
object under a camera somewhere else can
be recreated on this display it means
you can remotely manipulate objects in
the room that's sensing the movement you
have this depth sensing camera that
shooting are all these little infrared
dots and I can tell the exact position
of the hand and the movements of the
user in the sensing room based on this
information the display side moves up
and down this nine hundred blocks that
replicate the shape of the hand on the
other side
so what's in store for the future at the
moment they've got in essence 900 pixels
but imagine if it got up to the point of
like an HDTV which is like 2 million
pixels I mean things could actually
physically come out and grab you